do you think uh trump is gonna go away
now
or is there any chance that he's gonna
run in 2024 what's your ideas around
this
i have no idea and i don't i don't dare
make any predictions because all
predictions are aging very badly at the
moment
uh i mean is that can you think of a
single person who has made a good
prediction in the last five years
uh morgan housel who's a financial
expert tweeted at the start of last year
saying about how much time people had
spent analyzing the
2010 until 2019 decade of trading
and extrapolating out all of the
different charts for the coronavirus to
come in and just totally sideswipe
everything that they'd done yeah that's
the thing
like the political environment is very
unstable at the moment
uh so i i don't predict but
i wouldn't be surprised if in 2024 he
runs again
i expect that he will and i think he
would be
a powerful force if he did um less
powerful now that he's been
de-platformed from every silicon valley
platform
and that's what the silicon valley
cartel know they know that this has
reach and influence and power
so really if i were donald trump and i
were thinking about it i would choose an
alternative social media network
and make that the network that i used
and then you can get probably hundreds
of millions of people
to at least look at it occasionally if
not join it and actively participate
but i mean the the social media
alternatives parlor was doing
fantastically
well until they got de-platformed and
gab is also doing fantastically well
and they can't be de-platformed because
as i understand that gab
are responsible for their own
infrastructure although i've
been told that's not entirely correct so
i'm not sure about the details really
but uh but basically andrew torber who
runs gab has been de-platformed in the
same way that paulo was
and so he is uh protected against that
they can't do that twice
and so trump should choose a platform
that silicon valley can't de-platform
and get to work he's got a few years if
he wants to do it he's
he can do this you know he's got the
money he's got the time he's got
uh the political capital to do it as
well
especially as the ma the manga base um
generally don't feel that this was a
legitimate they think this was a stolen
election whether you agree with them or
not
um so if trump uh starts getting back
into the action
uh i think that he'll do very well the
thing is it also might be a wise
um political move to actually let the
situation breathe
for a while right because what joe biden
is doing at the moment
makes him by his own standards kind of
looked like a dictator
uh he was the one criticizing excessive
use of executive orders and then
30 of them plus in his first week and
it's like okay
what are you doing you know and the
radical radical changes you know
bringing
critical race theory training uh all you
know all of the changes to the military
of transgenderism and things like this
it's like okay these are these are
sweeping changes that biden is making
and they're not good changes they're not
they're not changes that the general
public actually endorses
you know how many how many of the
general public want frontline female
soldiers
probably not that many of them you know
it's it's very much the sort of
progressive wing of their party that's
driving the agenda
and biden's just leaping you know both
feet in you know he just doesn't seem to
care
about any any objections now and so it's
like right okay let him
govern badly give him enough give him
enough rope
exactly give him enough rope so if if i
i mean trump waits like six months for a
year
before getting like fully engaged back
into politics
then he might find himself with a very
weak opposition where they've
overextended
you know they've tried to impeach him
which i don't think is gonna work
because i don't think they're gonna get
the votes
and so that'll be a waste of their own
political capital it'll give
people like aoc time to sort of march
around on the field of victory and
be really insufferable and put a lot of
people's backs up just by the way that
they operate and i think that's
happening
um and it'll the republicans have kind
of been routed after the capital riot
uh and so they give them time to sort of
regroup allow biden to ruin things
and then come back in a big storm and
hopefully uh take it
but uh but again not a prediction just
the kind of fantasy of what i think
could happen
dude so one thing that malice said which
really really struck a chord with me
is people thought that trump
was the river when in fact he was the
dam
a lot of right leaning
americans felt like they were being
represented by trump
and look what happens when you take away
that damn they no longer have anybody
that's speaking for them
they no longer have anyone that they
feel is representing them so [ __ ] it
insurrection
i uh that there is definitely a strong
undercurrent of the republic is over in
a lot of the republican circles now um
which is not good
you know he's not good at the most
powerful country with the most nukes in
the world
yeah i'm not too worried about that um
but what it is
is if if america becomes consumed with
its own internal disputes then
people like china and russia are always
watching from the margins and seeking i
mean china's already been violating
taiwanese airspace and things like this
right this is not taking long joe biden
is not going to have a firm hand with
china like trump did
and it will not be to the benefit of the
united states
um and you i think you i think you're
really right about the damn
thing trump trump really seemed to have
been holding back a lot of
uh initiatives that really seem to have
a negative
intention towards the average american
person
uh in favor of fringe activist groups
who have been making their voices very
well heard but don't represent a very
sizable constituency
even necessarily of the minorities they
claim to represent
like for example feminists like very few
women are actually feminists
like less than 10 women self-identify as
a feminist
uh and whereas 80 of women will say well
yeah i think there should be
equality between men and women so the
overwhelming majority agree with the
basic feminist premise
but they won't identify as feminists
because they don't want to join the
activist group
because they can see that this is the
you know the man-hating lunatics
right and so the biden is catering to
these fringe
internet activists with everything and
so like let it
you know let it go it'll it'll be
insufferable
but um you'll when when
this has gone on for enough time
hopefully
someone from the republicans who is
capable and competent and decent will
come along
i've noticed that they're really going
hard on a senator called josh hawley
at the moment because he wanted to
represent his constituents concerns
about the lack of apparent transparency
and their belief in the invalidity of
the election
and the electoral process and he is
being treated as if he led some sort of
armed insurrection into the capital
which he didn't he was in there giving
his testimony when
the event occurred so the fact that
they're treating him
as if he was leading it is very
interesting to me and he hasn't backed
down on this either
he got the platform from his book and he
hasn't backed down and
so i'm i'm thinking someone like him is
probably
if because you know trump trump's going
to be in his late 70s by 2024
and as vital as trump is as energetic as
trump is
that is old you know and it is a very
stressful job and
etc uh but josh hawley looks like he's
in his 40s
um the right kind of age to start
pushing forward with this kind of if if
i mean he might not be that inclined he
might be a wall street
guy you know he might have been bought
off he might not be a populist in any
way but that's not the impression i've
got from him actually he seems to be
interested in representing
the sort of rural working class and the
rural interests
um and someone like that is definitely
necessary
for the american political system if it
wants to survive i think
i think if one side is just not
represented and one of the things you
notice about the democrats is they are
going
hard on their republican opponents they
are they are trying to extirpate them as
much as possible
and that's the exact wrong maneuver to
take if you think you're a legitimate
winner
you don't want to punish the opposition
for losing you know that's not what a
democratic system is meant to be
but instead they're acting like they
didn't win
you know they're acting like they've
done something wrong they're acting like
they've got guilty consciences
and uh and yeah i don't think it's
sustainable i think they'll overreach
you